you've got a lot of fresh talent around
she knows Smith
what else does Gino need to make the
jump from rookie to a second-year
quarterback who could be a team leader
in the NFL I think the big thing is what
Gino started to do at the end of the
year he figured out how to win in this
league one way is to protect the
football first and foremost then it's
obviously we got to score points but you
also got to protect that ball and I
think he did a tremendous job of that he
was so efficient at the end of the
season and that's why I was so excited
about how this team was finishing you
know we won three out of the last four
but as a team we kind of grew together
and you know we started figuring this
out a little bit so building on that
well Gino Smith have a Pro Bowl year
this year oh you know I don't I don't
know about that but you know we're just
which is what I be you know and it's
good a football team as we can be
regardless of the individual awards can
you lead them to the playoffs in 2014
well I I feel great about not just
putting it on one player but on our
football team I think our locker room
can lead us you know the guys in that
locker room the whole collection of 53 I
think is going to be our strength not
just one individual you know there's
gonna be teams with better better
quarterback than us better receiver than
us better defensive lineman than us
better head coach than us but
collectively that's the important thing
and I think one thing I know for sure is
is we're going to give everything we
have through preparation through work
ethic through desire passion we're going
to give it all out there